[Music]
on this thursday night new details about
canada's new
rapid covet 19 tests ottawa just bought
millions of them so why doesn't everyone
want one
plus parts of quebec enter a partial
lockdown
young canadians stressed it sucks and
struggling to get by
i work seven days a week the financial
pressures of the pandemic and the
difficulty
kick starting a career allegations of
rampant racism
in canada's health care system i don't
feel safe going to a hospital as an
indigenous person
right and even as a doctor what needs to
be done
for real change and some dog gone
recognition new honors unleashed for
bc's beloved top
doctor
global national with donna friesen
good evening and thanks for joining us
we have been warned there is no quick or
easy way out of this pandemic
that reality is hitting hard in quebec
tonight where millions of people are
back
under tighter restrictions starting
today and for at least 27 more days
a partial lockdown is in effect in three
virus hot spots montreal quebec city and
the bose region
that means bars and restaurants are
closed except for takeout
as are theaters casinos and museums no
park
gatherings or visits to other people's
homes are allowed
to help bars and restaurants get through
the next month the government is
offering to cover 80 percent of their
fixed
expenses i know we've made
some tough decisions in recent days
but they are lives in danger
and fighting the virus must remain our
top priority
here's what's worrying quebec is
reporting nearly 1 000 new cases today
over the past seven days it's recorded
an average of 793 cases
per day here's the rest of the country
it's important to point out the atlantic
bubble is working just one new case is
being reported in that region today
and some restrictions are now being
eased in pei in nova scotia
alberta has 173 new cases today
bc has 82. ontario has
538 new infections reported today that's
down from over 600 yesterday
but there is a problem with more and
more people in ontario getting tested
the province's testing backlog
is getting worse today there were more
than 82
000 tests waiting to be processed at
labs
and now there's more confusion over who
should be getting tested in ontario
for weeks now people were told everyone
who wants a test can get a test
and kids who had even one minor symptom
like a runny nose or sore throat
often needed a covid19 test before they
could go back to daycare or to school
now ontario public health says that's
not necessary
we are changing the policy or clarifying
that schools and day care should not be
requiring a negative covet test
in fact they shouldn't even require a
doctor's note
now rapid tests could in theory reduce
the backlog
and take some of the pressure off labs
in this country health canada has
approved a handful of rapid tests and
the federal government has committed to
buying millions
of one kind of rapid tests made by
abbott industries in the u.s
but ontario's premier said today he
doesn't want to rely on them
and as abigail beeman discovered it's
going to be quite some time before
millions of these rapid tests are
actually delivered
in an interview with global news health
canada's chief medical advisor says
while the government bought up to 7.9
million newly approved rapid tests
we're not getting them all at once and
we're not getting 8 million anytime
soon hundreds of thousands of tests
fairly shortly
within this first few months and then
moving into i think the total is
to 2.5 million tests that'll take us
into the early part of 2021.
dr supriya sharma says the tests will be
doled out based on several factors
per capita case numbers epidemiology of
outbreaks
and the rural urban split the provinces
and territories are in the process of
looking
at what their needs are and submitting
those to help canada we haven't received
those yet
the abbott id now is a pcr test it works
by detecting the virus's dna
back in the spring the u.s food and drug
administration flagged concerns about
its high false negatives and a new york
university study found that a different
rapid test
the cepheid performed better the trump
administration is now deploying a
different test from
abbott the binax now antigen test which
is based on proteins
what america has seen with abbott and
some of the other
rapid tests in terms of high false
negative rates
is not acceptable so as a result
united states policy has shifted the
other announcement that the prime
minister made about the
abbott testing that's going to help
don't get me wrong but it's not the
rapid test
i have confidence that they're going to
get this out and i really look forward
to it because it's a game changer health
canada says it can't comment on the
american concerns and data from the
spring
the version of the test that we did see
was supported with evid with evidence uh
to show that it was picking up cases
again with the nasal swabs um at a rate
of
at least 93 this test is not something
that
basically they've thrown at us and said
please here take it
without any additional testing they have
provided all the additional
clarification
after exposing some of those potential
weaknesses and that other test the new
york university study found performed
better
cepheid well that's one of the few
approved for use here too and it's
already
in use including in northern manitoba
canada has purchased about a million of
those tests
global news asked why not more compared
to the 8 million abbott tests
dr sharma said it had to do with supply
capacity what the company was able to
provide
in the short term abigail beeman global
news
ottawa now to some other covit 19
developments starting with that outbreak
at calgary's foothills hospital
according to public health officials a
fifth patient has now died of the virus
the number of infections is going up in
total 35 patients and 29 health care
workers have now tested positive
and at least 290 other health care
workers
are in isolation in ontario more than
140 000 personal support workers are
getting a pay raise
the province has announced a three
dollar an hour raise for workers in
nursing homes and home care
and a two dollar an hour raise for
workers in public hospitals
it is worth noting though the raise is
temporary and it's expected to end
next march it's also less than the four
dollar an hour pandemic pay psw's in
ontario got
earlier this year that raise ended in
august
in manitoba the federal covet alert app
is now active quebec is expected to roll
it out too in the next few days
when ontario first adopted the
technology in late july health canada
was hopeful it would become
widely used but bc alberta nova scotia
pei
and the territories still have not given
it the green light
thousands of recent graduates are facing
the end of a six-month grace period on
student loan payments
the federal government put a freeze on
paying back loans and interest
because of the pandemic that ends today
forcing many young people to deal with a
new wave of financial uncertainty
mike trolley reports
sean mcnally has been singularly focused
on his dream job
doing animation in the gaming world
the pandemic of course has put a lot of
dreams on hold
and mcnally now keeps his skills fresh
animating online
to an audience of followers you've gotta
be positive
otherwise people don't watch you but
it's not easy and even though the job
market has yet to thaw
the freeze on student loans is over so
since graduating in the spring
he's struck out finding work didn't
qualify for serb benefits
and his school bills have now come due
because of that
i'm going to fall even further behind
and
i it's it's it sucks the most recent
stats can
numbers show 23 percent fewer young
canadians are in full-time jobs compared
to this time last year
count aisha akaredi in that group after
her husband lost his job
she answered the call to work in a
long-term care facility
when few others would but it's contract
work
and far from the social services job
she'd studied for
i guess i don't have choice so when the
time comes
you know what i don't really know that's
why it's really really an attack for me
right now i don't rest i work seven days
a week
so i have to
pay bills unless ottawa freezes student
loan payments again
she'll have another bill on her already
full plate
her only hope for a deferral is if she
qualifies for the student loan repayment
assistance plan these pandemic graduates
aren't unique to having a hard time
launching their careers
but analysts say current financial
pressures could see them stay in jobs
they need
instead of jobs they want you know i
wouldn't look down on anybody who's in
that situation and say
where are you going to get started or
get launched nobody should be putting
judgment on these students
they have to do it a whole different way
they have
no other choice mike darling global news
toronto
this weekend we'll find out who will
succeed elizabeth may as leader of the
green party of canada
eight candidates are running including a
woman named enemy paul who is jewish
her candidacy appears to have exposed
what some say is a troubling
anti-semitic undercurrent in the party
as our chief political correspondent
david aiken reports it's not the first
time the greens have had to deal with
this
we will launch a plan to solve the
climate emergency
human rights lawyer anime paul is by
some measures
the front runner to become the next
green party leader
according to figures provided by the
party she leads all candidates in terms
of fundraising and number of
contributors
we believe that we can win seats with
integrity with
good public policy with evidence-based
public policy and that's really what
it's about for
for me but as popular as she's been with
many green supporters
others she says have attacked her for
being jewish
i have been subjected to what can only
be described as an
unrelenting onslaught of comments and
commentary and trolling
online it's harder the first time
canada's greens have had to deal with
accusations of anti-semitism within its
ranks
in 2014 then party president paul estrin
also jewish
quit in disgust after being attacked by
some in the party
for condemning the actions of hamas
terrorists
and in 2018 the party's justice critic
dimitri lascaris
accused two jewish liberal mps of being
more loyal to israel
than to the prime minister lascaris's
attack was
widely condemned by all party leaders
though he rejects the view his comments
were anti-semitic
well i think one has to really get a
good handle on what anti-semitism is
and understand that legitimate criticism
of the state of israel
is in no way shape or form anti-semitic
lascaris is now a top contender to
become
leader of the green party second to paul
in fundraising in fact
and he rejects the idea that the green
party has a problem with anti-semites
i think that there is a serious problem
with anti-semitism in this country and i
think where you're going to find that
is predominantly on the right wing of
the political spectrum still he's a
contender only after
overcoming opposition to his candidacy
from party executives and from the last
leader elizabeth may
who fired him as justice critic after
his 2018 comments
my views and the party's views are solid
on this
i think you know to the extent that
anybody
is running for leader of the green party
of canada who has expressed anti-semitic
views
they shouldn't have been allowed to run
in allowing lascaris into the leadership
race
the party's governing council would only
say that it's quote
concerns were satisfied and that it
trusts
in its membership donna all right david
aiken in ottawa thanks
the federal government is under
increasing pressure tonight to clarify
its position on
indigenous fisheries a second nova
scotia first nation launched a
self-regulated lobster fishery today
it's part of a new effort to assert
their inherent right to fish for what's
called a
moderate livelihood that right was
upheld by the supreme court of canada
more than two decades ago
but as ross lord explains there is still
no clarity about what
moderate livelihood means
at the st peter's wharf in cape breton
indigenous pride is on display
a drum band performing the migma honor
song and the grand chief
blessing a small fleet of lobster boats
so glamorous
rpg
[Applause]
this is the second indigenous lobster
fishery to launch in nova scotia in
recent weeks the bolo attack first
nation chose to do it
on treaty day which nova scotia
designates for promoting public
awareness about migma culture
and rights it's an inherent right you
know we've been fighting for this for
20 some years and resistance every which
way so it's
there's only one way to do it and it's
on the water the first
self-regulated lobster fishery in
southwestern nova scotia
was met with heated protests and
widespread cutting of lobster traps by
commercial fishers
who insist everyone should fish within
the same season
there were no immediate signs of
protests this time as a growing number
of first nations
planned to follow suit i'll remember to
escazoni and
and annapolis and i know a few other
accumulator bands also looking at the
same thing
we're all going to be using the same
plan as the number of first nations
fisheries increases
so does pressure on the federal
government to clarify
whether it supports them i'd say it puts
definitely pressures on your members of
parliament
this cape breton liberal mp is also a
boatload tech member
the reason why it's not clear it's
because there is not consensus within
the migmaw communities or within the
federal government
of what a moderate livelihood means
jaime batiste proposes establishing a
new entity led by the migma community
so all sides can reach a common
understanding of how best to share what
the ocean has to offer
ross lord global news st peters nova
scotia
if it's not bread then what is it coming
up an unusual court ruling
in ireland
this stunning footage is from california
this is what firefighters are facing as
they battle what's called the glass fire
just north of san francisco
it's destroyed more than 22 thousand
hectares and it's burned down more than
200 buildings including homes and
wineries
it's only about five percent contained
and it's just one of nearly
30 fires that are still burning in
california at least 30 people have been
killed
and more than 90 000 people are under
evacuation orders
adding to the concern more hot dry and
windy weather is in the forecast
well it doesn't seem like there needs to
be a legal definition of bread
but there is now in ireland the fast
food chain
subway has been told by the irish
supreme court that its bread is not
in fact bred the case centers on
ireland's
value-added sales tax it like the gst
and the hst is not applied to basic
groceries but does apply to snacks junk
foods and candies
a subway franchisee in ireland believe
the company's bread
qualifies as a staple food and should be
exempt from the tax
but a panel of supreme court judges
disagreed ruling that the bread subway
uses contains way too much
sugar to be legally considered bread
which makes it more like cake it seems
[Music]
still ahead what joyce eshequan's video
just before she died
exposed in canada's health care system
you're watching global national
it was one of the last acts of a dying
woman the cell phone video joyce
escherquan took as she lay in a quebec
hospital bed pleading for help has
exposed an ugly reality indigenous
leaders say exists in our health care
system
a second nurse has now been fired from
that hospital but indigenous leaders say
the racism eshequan faced from the
hospital staff is not
at all unusual it's that she managed to
capture it on facebook live
otherwise her death would just be
another forgotten statistic
heather urix west reports and a warning
some viewers may find the video
disturbing dr lindsay kroshu is a family
physician
and a researcher at the university of
calgary
but i don't feel safe going to a
hospital as an indigenous person
right and even as a doctor when i was a
medical student
uh there was this indigenous woman um
yes she was a drug user and we needed to
put a central line into her
and the um the the the doctor says
she doesn't deserve anesthesia kroshu
says
the examples of anti-indigenous racism
within canada's healthcare system
are so common that the disturbing video
of joyce eshequan's final moments
did not come as a surprise in the video
the mother of seven
is in visible distress while staff
members can be heard
making racist and derogatory comments it
wasn't
entirely surprising given what i've seen
in the context of the review i've been
doing
mary ellen tepella fond is a former b.c
judge who has been tasked by bc's
provincial government
to investigate indigenous specific
racism within bc's health care system
the investigation was launched after
disturbing allegations of racism in
emergency rooms
so far she's examined more than 550
cases
finding evidence that racism is
pervasive and she doesn't believe the
problem
is bc's alone there is a need for a
national
attention to it and there's a need for
leadership inside health professions
when have i ever known anybody who's
indigenous to go into the health care
system and have a good experience
it's rare it's rare senator yvonne boyer
who is indigenous
says the work being done in bc needs to
be replicated
across the country until we start
realizing that there is a problem
then you can keep sweeping it under the
rug
and there's going to be another 50
joyce cases come up because as
investigations like the one in bc
have shown there have already been other
deaths not captured on cell phone video
and without change there will likely be
more
heather urex west global news calgary
next navigating through 2020 grieving
building trust and adjusting our mindset
somehow it's become october of 2020
which means we're closer to the end of
what will always be known as the year of
the pandemic
we're learning to live with it but
there's no escaping its
impact not only are more than one
million people around the world
known to have died from covid19 it has
altered how all of us
live tonight crystal gomencing takes a
look at the stress it's created
and the toll it's taking covet 19
is more than symptoms spread and the
number of
cases i think every person who dies of
covid19
has a family a community that they're
associated with
and those losses are are difficult
and i think loss and grief in the
pandemic is something that's a very
different experience
families haven't been allowed to say
goodbye or even
grieve in the same manner more than one
million lives cut
short because of the virus and it's
likely the number of dead worldwide
is higher than the official reports the
toll on doctors and hospital staff
is immense i think in the icu and in the
emergency department the teams are tired
um they have been working tirelessly
since the beginning of this pandemic
and as soon as we started to see a fall
off in the kova 19 numbers we started to
see a return of
the non-coveted work that we all have to
do
with hospitalizations rising restricting
social interactions wearing masks
and washing our hands are all more
important than ever
linda bold is a behavioral scientist and
public health researcher
she says people are tired so buy-in will
be even harder
i think that a lot of people were naive
about the fact that what was required
for a pandemic
is almost unprecedented intervention in
people's daily lives so the state
having a very aggressive role and not
considering
a how long that would be required or be
the types of communication that were
required to take the public with them
and to build trust following the advice
of public health officials is the best
course of action especially as
researchers
urge the public to be realistic about
when a vaccine will be widely available
crystal gomencing global news london
and that is global national for this
thursday i'm donna friesen tonight's
your canada will melt your heart
meet bonnie and henry two guide dog
puppy recruits they're named in honor of
bc's provincial health officer the guide
dog group says it's a fitting tribute as
the puppies will grow up to provide the
same kindness
calmness and guidance as dr bonnie henry
does
thanks for watching hope to see you here
again tomorrow
take care of yourselves bye-bye
[Music]
you